no
what's going to get people to wake up is
that they don't have any money
that'll wake them up well then we're not
on our way so
yeah most americans live paycheck to
paycheck they spend frivolously
they don't think about the future in
saving and security and more money you
have the more power you have they don't
think about it they want what they want
when they want it but now they have far
less money than they had 18 months ago
and that's not going to subside anytime
soon
so the gasoline thing the food thing the
clothing thing uh everything
that's waking up some people who go
these people hurt me
these progressives hurt me biden hurt me
that's far overwhelms abortion gun
control any of that it's that i'm
getting hurt by these people
so i'm going to vote for the other
people and i think that's what you're
going to see
so to that end what do you make of the
the splitting of america in that way
that we're just going to have very very
different states as i think you know i
lived in california for the last eight
years finally moved to florida six
months ago and as i keep telling
everybody i genuinely feel like i live
in another country you're right i do
still live in the united states i
suppose but i live in a free state here
and i did not live in a free state only
3 000 miles away
well the social civil war is well
underway
we take a dramatic
populist leader
to
you know speak frankly to the nation and
say is this what you want again it's
just like new york this is what you want
if not let's kind of reason
and find solutions to vexing problems
that's what it's all about problem
solving
progressives they want to knock out
what america is they don't like the
country
they don't care about the constitution
they don't want capitalism
they want equity they want favoritism
for minority groups
they want nothing to do with traditional
america
but again they're not
there there's about 20 25 of those hate
america people and they'll never admit
that by the way they'll always cloak it
but the rest 75 percent if they would
come together they could overwhelm this
destructive progressive movement but
again
they're lost in space cyberspace
and that's what that's what we have
do you sense that maybe some of that's
turning around not only because of the
roe v wade thing which kicks some of
this back to the states but some of the
other decisions the the the concealed
carry decision that some of this stuff
is putting the power back in the hands
of the people and maybe that gets some
more people to wake up
no
what's going to get people to wake up is
that they don't have any money
that'll wake them up well then we're on
our way so
yeah most americans live paycheck to
paycheck
they spend frivolously
they don't think about the future in
saving and security and more money you
have the more power you have they don't
think about it they want what they want
when they want it but now they have far
less money than they had 18 months ago
and that's not going to subside anytime
soon
so the gasoline thing the food thing the
clothing thing
everything
that's waking up some people who go
these people hurt me
these progressives hurt me biden hurt me
that's far overwhelms abortion gun
control any of that it's that i'm
getting hurt by these people
so i'm going to vote for the other
people and i think that's what you're
going to see so you think we're in some
kind of red wave situation i mean that's
that's what everyone's saying but i i
keep telling people you got to give the
devil as due it's like they can do
anything right before the elections i
don't even know what i mean by that
exactly covid ii mail-in ballots
etcetera etcetera who knows well it's
coming down fast so the summer is here
and the government doesn't function in
the summer
and the media doesn't function
either everybody's off they don't care
uh so it fires up again after labor day
and that's just two months before the
midterms it's far too little time for
the byte administration to really do
anything
you have a collapsing airline industry
and i'm the poster boy for that i
alerted everybody
uh
that it was happening
uh i got hammered but i don't care what
i did was right it was proper it was
just
uh i shouldn't have cursed the guy
but
the guy deserved it he deserved it and
i'm an irish guy from long island and
you know you pushed me so far
but anyway uh i do believe that the
republicans will take the house and the
senate i think a lot of democrats will
stay home and i think the hispanic
voting bloc will go republican and that
will overwhelm the progressives in
november
there's about 20 chance i'm wrong but 80
that i'm right
since you brought it up i have to ask
you're going to turks and caicos you're
ready to get on vacation get out of
there get out of the grinds why not just
fly private bill what are you doing you
got a little cash come on
look
i got up at five in the morning to make
a seven a.m flight
okay my assistant tracked the flight
plane was there everything was fine
weather was fine
so i get to the gate
delay
everybody's in the same boat on me
one hour
two hours
three hours four hours five hours
okay dave five hours people are coming
to me
in jfk at the terminal
asking me to do something
right to find out if the plane's gonna
take off
right so they're asking me so all i did
was walk over and ask for a supervisor
a guy who could barely speak english
came out
i said can you tell us what the
situation is
he gave me
attitude and the rest as they say is
history do you think the airline
situation that that situation where
every time you go to an airport now
there's delays cancellations i mean the
last five times i've been to airports
been absolute disasters uh that that's
indicative of of sort of everything
we're talking about here that the system
itself is no longer functioning properly
we don't hire functioning people we
don't hire people that speak english no
but the bug stops with nobody et cetera
this airline thing could be solved in a
week all right
who's the secretary of transportation
dave that's gay pete that's what we call
him on this show gay pete
okay so buddha judge is in charge
if he wanted to he could levy draconian
fines
on all of the airlines for being delayed
for five hours for no reason remember
delta airlines flew to turks caicos at
the same time and got off so when
jetblue said it was weather everyone
knew they were lying yeah yeah there's a
lot of that yeah okay
okay
so buddha judge can say to the airlines
if you don't have a legitimate excuse
for delay or cancellation you're fine
250 000 per flight
you do it got the power to do it
won't do it
now
you say
well
that might not be fair the airlines
could appeal the fine
and you set up a little
apparatus for them to do it
but i guarantee you if pete buddha judge
the director of uh secretary of
transportation has the power to do it
did it you would see remarkably
the whole airline industry be
responsible because they're
irresponsible now
so why doesn't pete boot a judge do that
i knew you were going to ask that that
was it was coming it was coming
right in your head
because pete drew the judge like
president biden doesn't know what the
deuce he's doing
he is a mayor of south bend indiana
where his biggest decision on thursday
was should we open the park
okay
that's it
he doesn't know how to run anything
he's an affirmative action hire yeah
that's why we call him here
he buddha judge knows it
the bible administration came in didn't
hire on merit who can we find out who
really understands transportation so we
don't have supply line problems
and we can get the airlines regulated so
they take off who can we get who really
knows that wasn't it
it was well we need a lifestyle guy
here's pete
okay
kamala harris is she qualified to run
the president to run the united states
of america dave is kamala harris
qualified to run it was this country she
does know that ukraine is small and that
russia is big that counts as something
doesn't it
no
uh she's there because she's an
affirmative action higher
so when you have an incompetent at the
top biden he's comfortable hiring other
incompetents
that's the way it is that's what we have
all right so let's move from
incompetence to perhaps some competence
that could maybe get involved in this
obviously you're an admirer and friend
of uh president trump and you guys did
your tour together for quite some time
uh we've got a great situation going on
here in florida with ron desantis what
do you make of what's going to happen
with the republicans and and
do you have any insight into what
trump's going to do i mean it all seems
like he's going that every day it's
another hint that seems where it's all
headed right
yeah i mean no doubt trump wants to run
for president and 24 he's raising money
to do so he has an announce because if
he announces now in 22 campaign finance
laws immediately kick in that will
constrict his fundraising for his
political action committees so he's not
going to
formally announce till next year
um
donald trump has problems uh no doubt
about it
uh he didn't handle uh the sixth january
sixth thing well
uh he continues to harp on the election
which is not a good political way to be
because he does have a strong record
have you said that if you look at
him about the about january 6 yeah
he doesn't listen to anybody donald
trump never listens to anybody's part of
his charm
he never has listened to anybody the
only person on earth that donald trump
ever listened to
was his father fred trump okay and that
was about business not politics
so anyway um
donald trump if you
and that's what the history tour that i
went out with trump on
if you look at the way he
ran the country
he was very successful because he ran it
on a deal-making opposition the reason
they didn't have trouble with putin is
because trump made a deal with putin i
don't know what that deal is but they
had a deal
now putin's hackers they caused a little
bit trouble but putin himself didn't
as soon as trump was gone
taliban in afghanistan putin and russia
and myriad others said okay now we got a
weak guy we don't have trump because
trump's
he's going to hurt us
and that's why i wrote killing the
killers i show you
in that book how trump handled isis
al-qaeda and the iranians
it was pretty tough
i don't think you could get tougher if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell